la fuite
émotion et colère d'une petite foule
autour du musée félix éboué à cayenne le
conseil général soit transformé en
bureau la maison natale de l'homme
illustres du pays premier gouverneur
noir en 1936 le projet est perçu comme
un outrage à la mémoire
une poignée d'irréductibles pour tenter
de sauver le nuisible
une pétition signes de résistance face à
une décision que personne ne comprend
c'est ici qu'a grandi félix éboué un
homme au destin hors du commun le
conseil général de transformer ce musée
en bureaux administratifs un lieu
historique que l'association mémoires
croisées ne veut pas voir disparaître
c'est une aberration pour nous ne
comprenons pas sûr que ça a été fait
sans la consultation de la population
colère des historiens et incompréhension
de la population beaucoup se dit choquée
par la décision du conseil général
quelqu'un car info 21 quelqu'un qui a
une voix de métro au fait sa liste à
paris où ses marques et félix éboué donc
quand même pourquoi en guyane se serait
permis ce sont kenzy est une aberration
on ne comprend pas partout dans le monde
o les peuples consentent qu'ils aient eu
un personnage est marqué l'histoire
locale au mondial il essaie de préserver
son espace et son lieu de vie de choix
s'impose au conseil général
le premier offrira cette personnalité la
place qu'elle mérite dans notre histoire
le second plus nuisible pour les
nouvelles générations laisser s'éteindre
la mémoire
e